it's as much about competition as it is
about laughter getting heated there
[Laughter]
on the court a game of pickleball feels
quick
tense
full of joy
Brad Chapman used to compete in
badminton now he trains for victory in
pickleball
going to tournaments and just like that
adrenaline rush you get from fighting
for the win just super exciting Brad won
the 2022 Canadian national men's doubles
in his age group he's hoping to add
another Trophy this time at a packed
event in Edmonton
this is one of the first tournaments
that I've played in as a local
tournament with money on the line and so
that always puts a little bit more
pressure on to do well
but to claim Glory they'll have to beat
hadothul a silver medalist at the
national championships and a close
friend knowing how he plays knowing some
of his tells I think is a very big
Advantage for me and for him playing me
as well he can read me just like a book
the two practice together often it can
be tough to find Space so they use this
makeshift cord in an industrial
Warehouse owned by hado's employer both
men want to turn pro something that is
possible in pickleball but first they'll
have to face off in the final traveling
across North America traveling to
tournaments driving through blizzards go
play tournaments in Edmonton I love it
you know it's a passion of mine
I'm a full-on addict
avocado and hundreds of thousands of
others have fallen in love with this
game in communities big and small
pickleball players flock to indoor and
outdoor courts cradling their paddle and
plastic swiss cheese looking bald I do
think it is the fastest growing sport in
Canada and probably North America Carla
Anderson is the executive director of
pickleball Canada last year January of
2022 it was over a million people in
Canada playing that means from 2021 to
2022 the number of players in Canada
tripled
the perception note there certainly that
it is for senior citizens and that is
changing the fastest growing population
in Canada was 18 to 34 year olds the
reasons for its popularity varied it's
easy to pick up as a low cost of entry
and it's social
hi guys Hi pickleballers how are we
today
[Applause]
[Music]
we wanted to check it out for ourselves
so we met up with a group of players at
the Etobicoke olympium in the West End
of Toronto how did you even hear about
it my friends played all the indoor
facilities shut down people resorted to
outdoor courts I was like oh I really
want to pick them up
such a social sport yeah we get to know
a lot of people so the time has come
everyone I'm on the court and I'm going
to play John Cameron head of the
Etobicoke pickleball Association showed
me the ropes back here
just serve on your hand sounds good
there you go perfect
Geez Louise
closer sorry
whoa sorry I'm sorry
that sucked yeah
[Music]
we got a point
thanks so much for everything wow ladies
good game you guys are so good
across the country in Victoria another
intense pickleball game is underway
the desire to play on the island has
grown exponentially and Connie McCann
spends most of her days trying to find
space for her 500 Plus members
I wake up thinking that I'm in the
middle of a giant snowball and it's
rolling downhill and it's just getting
bigger and I don't know where it's going
you go Holly
part of the problem here and other
places there aren't enough courts to
meet demand
and the sport just is wild and
municipalities are not really ready for
this I mean how could they be so
pickleballers have had to be creative
and turn empty parking lots in outdoor
courts into areas to play causing
friction with traditional Sports what
we're seeing is that there are tennis
courts that haven't been used some of
the facilities their courts might not be
filled and they're changing some of
their tennis courts into pickleball
courts here in Victoria some players
would really like to have all of the
tennis courts marked for pickleball but
we need to focus on getting our own
space the battle for space has given way
for another growing pain this
foreign
courts the sound of pickleball has
triggered clashes between players and
residents who find the whack the ball
makes when hit way too loud complaints
have resulted in court cases fines and
even Bans
last spring the city of Victoria barred
players from this court area because of
noise concerns but Connie and her Club
weren't having it
they held a pickleball protest at City
Hall to fight the decision we brought it
to the attention of the mayor and
Council front and center I think they
wanted us to go away and there's one
thing that over 55 year old people do
not do is go away
and it worked Connie says they now have
a few dedicated courts and their
Association raised funds to build a
sound barrier more courts would be a
solution for a lot of the issues make
sure they're not around very populated
residence area
we decided to measure the intensity of
the sound ourselves so we brought a
decibel reader to the olympium with us
so we're just gonna eavesdrop on this
match here
okay so we're starting off at 71.1 so
78.9
74.8 and back down to where we started
in the 60s
to give you perspective a normal
conversation is around 60 decibels and a
ringing telephone is 80. according to
the CDC
folks this isn't a science but we're
definitely getting some diverse readings
here as the game heats up so too do the
readings
okay that enthusiasm that registered
84.7 while our indoor findings didn't
show any off the chart numbers those
complaining say it's the noise produced
by the ball repeatedly striking the
paddle day after day that's irritating
at the tournament in Edmonton the thrill
of pickleball fills the air
[Applause]
[Music]
the players of all levels have crammed
themselves into this venue to take their
shot at top prize it's hopping in here
there's lots of lots of people high
energy so
to be part of it
Brad and Hano with their doubles
Partners have won their games in their
bracket they now find themselves once
again in the final
it's really funny that we're always
playing against each other in finals and
I think it's really special
gold bill
so far how to end his teammate have
secured the first game
the matches are unnervingly close and
Brad and his partner take game two
haddo's team calls a timeout in the
third to change tactics
Brad has honestly one of the most
amazing smashes I've ever had to defend
he puts crazy angles very deceptive
their new strategy works but Brad's team
comes roaring back in the fourth so it
went down to the very last game so it
was very tight the whole way through
they just managed to come out on top
first place from Claire
Joel and hello
[Applause]
it felt amazing felt great such a
euphoric feeling losing hurts it's never
fun nobody wants to lose take lessons
away from it but in the moment it's hard
to hard to swallow this tournament is
just one more step in their Quest To Go
Pro with pickleball manias monstrous
increase in participation there are now
two professional U.S tours and given
that pickle Buzz shows no sign of
slowing down the goal will be to find
solutions to let the once perky sport
find a dedicated place to call home we
have to catch up in terms of
infrastructure venues we are definitely
behind there but it'll come as soon as
we get more dedicated pickleball space
it's just going to help the sport
continue to grow very rapidly
[Music]